hey guys welcome to another hd tutorial
this one will be on how to revert to the
classic start menu um if you're using
windows vista so this is a really quick
tutorial all you're going to do is right
click your taskbar and hit properties
and go under the start menu tab
and that's it right there you see the
classic start menu option you check it
and it'll give you the look and
functionality of previous versions of
windows so if i were if i were to apply
that right now
and if i click on the start menu it'll
take a while actually for the first time
it loads but after that it's very very
quick you just basically the windows
this to start menu
all the programs are fanned out instead
of actually being within the start menu
so you guys can just mess around with
this and see if you like it or not
actually it puts a few icons on your
desktop
um that you you can delete if you want
to so what i'm going to do is delete
these icons
real quick
and
now if i want to revert if i want to go
back to the regular windows vista start
menu it's the same exact process right
click and hit properties
start menu and classic the regular start
menu which gives you easy access to
folders and such the windows start menu
now when i open my start menu again
it'll have all the recently used
programs that i had in the original
windows vista start menu including these
which are videos i've recently done
and all the programs that i already had
so it'll keep all your regular start
menu settings the size of it and
everything so if you actually had
customized your start menu you would
still have all these options that you
actually used for your default settings
in your original
windows vista start menu so i hope that
helps you guys uh if you don't really
like the windows start menu or it tends
to take too long to load that is exactly
how you change back so thanks for
watching peace
you